good morning John it's Friday April 13th
I don't know very much about Kurt
Vonnegut but it's pretty clear that the
English nerdfighters do and with them I
mourn in times of mourning it's easy to
concentrate on the increase of worldsuck
the Brotherhood 2.0 isn't about
recognizing when suck levels increase
it's about decreasing suck levels this
stuff on my head is for Kurt Vonnegut
but this video is for decreasing world
suck let's spend a little bit of time
talking about global warming as my last
video showed I spent an awful lot of
time thinking about global warming and
while a vast majority of Americans have
decided that global warming is a really
big deal and that we really need to do
something about it so far no one is
doing anything about it I mean we are
individually people are buying Priuses
and turning off lights and using compact
fluorescent light bulbs which I heartily
encourage you to do what needs to be
done can't be done just by individuals
there are pretty much three types of
entities in the world
they're people there are corporations
and their governments we got the people
we need the corporations and the
governments and I'll tell you what it
feels like we've got the corporations
more than we have the government which
is just screwed up so if you want to
talk about decreasing suck levels
worldwide we need to talk about
decreasing temperatures worldwide or at
least decrease carbon emissions and just
by coincidence
tomorrow is step it up day step it up as
a campaign started by Bill McKibben the
guy who wrote that book I told you to
read basically it's a campaign to say
okay Congress now we all agree that
there's a problem and you all agree that
there's a problem now you should do
something and the good news is that
almost everybody can participate in a
step it up event because they're like
they're everywhere we've got one in
Missoula and one in Glacier in one
Corvallis
I mean in terms of Montana that's like
having three block parties on the same
block this is a big deal there's like
400 of these things going on in New York
City alone basically everybody's getting
together and having a bloody fantastic
time trying not to emit very much carbon
and getting really angry at Congress I
mean I love being angry at Congress John
I know that there's a bunch of these
cool things going on in New York and I
shall
you to attend one of them I want to see
video of you at a step it up rally even
if you have to have a step it up rally
of one I want to see you asking Congress
to step it up for 2007 and actually make
some change also I know there's some eco
nerdfighters out there I want to see you
guys stepping it up to my personal step
it up project I'm going to turn off my
house all of it all of it you won't see
me on the Internet I won't be there
because my house will be off I will also
be attending a rally in downtown
Missoula and I will be gardening because
that doesn't take any power and it's a
good thing to do anyways I have to go
because this thing is falling off my
head I'll see you on Monday